ou madame l'infirmière oui c'est moi qui
vous ai appelé oui il faudra que
j'écrive à ma femme un ah bah oui je
vais encore avoir du mal bon ça vous
ennuierait pas d'écrire à ma place je
vous dictez merci ma chérie eux
bah ouais je suis pro moderne c'est à
l'hôpital que je t'écris pour te dire
que tout va très bien pour moi bien sûr
je ne serais pas auprès de toi pour le
15 ou mais je pense que d'ici noël
je serai remis de mes nombreuses
fractures pas quand je suis sorti du
coma j'ai appris avec surprise que tu
n'étais jamais venu me voir et que tu
n'avais même pas demandé de mes
nouvelles
es-tu distraite
je suis sûr que tu avais déjà oublié ce
qui m'était arrivé points par contre
quand l'inter note à téléphoner et que
tu lui ai répondu il peut toujours
crever son minable
là je crois que tu exagères tu n'avais
pas le droit de parler comme ça surtout
devant un étranger je sais bien que nous
nous étions chamailler la veille que
j'avais eu le tort d'élever la voix
enfin ponctuellement mais quand même
c'est pas beau de boue des points
d'exclamation l'assureur m'a écrit pour
me dire que j'étais responsable de
l'accident
vu que je n'étais pas en état de
conduire à cause des coups de marteau
que tu m'avais donné sur tu parles comme
si je n'en avais pas l'habitude
il est vrai que lui ne connais pas ton
caractère emporté points de suspension
le commissaire affirme que c'est toi qui
a saboté la direction de ma voiture
les voisins sont vus en train de scier
mon volant alors là je m'insurge
tu sais comme je tiens à mes affaires je
n'avais pas le droit de toucher à ma
voiture
c'est une grande indélicatesses si tout
continue comme ça je finirai par croire
que tu ne m'aimes plus voilà si tout est
même pas de formules de politesse
qu'est-ce qu'il va être vexé